it's time for drew's news your daily
jiggle of that good news jell-o
and with me at the desk i can't say
jello without doing this his favorite
jell-o flavor is red rossi ross
matthew um
first up um the hardest working woman in
showbiz has done it again
nme reports madonna's new live concert
film madame x
is out on paramount plus right now
cameras followed her on tour dates for
75 days around the world and i was lucky
enough to be in the audience for the new
york premiere
uh-huh and i got to ask her a question
madonna
anyway she would not approve of any of
this goofiness i feel like she's so damn
cool
um but i wanted to share the moment with
you so take a look
my question for you was have you said no
to anything
that you wish you had said yes to and
what was that thing oh that's not good
good question yeah i was given the
script to the matrix
i was offered the role of
trinity yeah and
i was kidding i read this script i'm
like this is the stupidest i've ever
read what i turned it down
okay
uh i'm sorry do you know how cool it is
that you get to go to opening night and
you get to ask madonna a question the
truth is i used to be all up in the club
with madonna and shawn back in the day
so i've really known her most of my life
of course of course but she's also still
madonna and i'm geeking out and freaking
out but this concert film is really
unlike other concert films that makes
you feel like you've traveled to europe
and you're seeing exquisite performance
art i felt like i had left
the country and gone to some beautiful
place and she's wearing a black wig in
it and the people in it are just
it's it's really incredible yeah i met
madonna one time and yeah
she um
she goes like this and i like touched
her hand and i felt like i was touched
for the very first time
i was well uh okay oh hey drew we've got
a little follow-up for you remember
earlier this week if you were watching
uh we played a game of chicago trivia
and it was chicago native ike baron
holds versus chicago blackhawks jonathan
taves and seth jones the stakes were
high they did trivia and the loser
agreed to be posted on a huge
drew yellow billboard for all of chicago
to see and the loser kept their word
take a look at this i know this is real
this is not a mock-up we love the drew
barrymore show
uh we're in chicago
guess what chicago we're coming for you
oh yeah oh yeah we're bringing the show
to you so watch out because we're coming
to town soon we love you
stay tuned for that
[Music]
you